our Camila Cabello and Shawn Mendes back
on oh my God this is a real thing well
fans seem to think so after the singer
dropped a 20-second snippet of a new
song titled June Gloom how come you're
just so much better
it's gonna end ever
yeah those specific lyrics about
Coachella seemingly allude to her recent
weekend with Sean at the music festival
where they spend time together and even
locked lips oh my God like we're we're
kissing now following their PDA moment A
source told E.T Camila and Sean have
been spending time together months
before and cleared the air about their
breakup as for the kiss well our source
says they let loose and we're just
having fun
those feelings are gonna come and I
think you just gather more and more
tools to cope with them in like healthy
ways and this wouldn't be the first time
Camila shared her feelings about Sean
through music
[Music]
the Grammy winners track bomb bomb is
largely believed to be about their 2021
split yeah
[Music]
thanks for another person again and then
you'll be crying on the bathroom floor
again and that is kind of like the
cycles of of change like things just
change you never know what's around the
corner
spark more speculation that Camila and
Sean rekindled their romance check out
this video of the two Hand in Hand
during a night stroll in Santa Monica an
eyewitness tells Ichi they were alone
and just walking casually adding Sean
and Camila were holding hands and seemed
deep in conversation they looked very
comfortable happy and in love I think
the truth about being celebrities and
being in a relationship is that it's
super tricky because
there's a lot of people who want to know
at this point our source says the X's
are not back together but they're still
undeniable chemistry between them and
everyone around them can feel it
[Music]
I mean we're all here for Sean Mila 2.0
and the new music